this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armories museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode jonathan is taking a look
at a classic of the battle royale genre
playerunknown's battlegrounds on the gun
on the action bars it says
m1897 and it also says shotgun i don't
think i can think of a single shotgun
that has the word shotgun written on it
because it's a shotgun
if you're a fan of content like this
make sure to subscribe as we have plenty
of episodes with jonathan in our back
catalogue as well as our show loadout
which takes a look at gaming's most
iconic weapons and of course if there
are any other games guns or mechanics
that you guys want to see jonathan break
down do let us know in the comment
section down below right let's take a
look at the guns of pubg
right so this on the face of it is a
rifle near and dear to the hearts of all
ex-british army soldiers or at least
of a certain age because this is
supposed to be the british slr see also
the canadian and the australian slr now
slr was is an abbreviation for
self-loading rifle now this is not
technically the name of this rifle this
is the class of weapon that this
particular rifle sat within if that
makes sense um suffice to say that just
eyeballing this the proportions look off
the flash eliminator looks absolutely
enormous i mean it's very long on the on
the slr but that's very fat as well the
magazine's weirdly short i don't know
why that is is that because they have
limited the capacity artificially from
the 20 rounds it should be don't know
haven't played pub g guess i'll find out
does have the folding cocking handle of
the slr but it is permanently unfolded
so we have we have um
hints of what this should look like and
it's reasonably detailed but it's not
quite coming together as a really
faithful representation of an slr and
l1a1 for me let's have a look at the
gameplay
[Applause]
so my first impression of the model for
this rifle doesn't quite meet the
gameplay in that that magazine that
looks far too short i suppose that's
worth talking about so this this
incremental increase in magazine
capacity is obviously not realistic
that's well
it's realistic in terms of extended base
plates on magazines so when you see
especially pistol magazines with a big
bumper on the bottom of the magazine
that's not just there to protect it if
it falls to the floor that allows a
little bit more usually usually plus two
two more rounds side-by-side-ish just
extends the body of the magazine there's
there's a
there's a reality junction there if you
like but um i don't think we see the
magazine change on the gun so i'm
surprised this wasn't modeled with the
correct length of magazine basically the
the magazine depicted on the on the gun
and on the little icon is just too short
our old friend the thompson i've got a
nice view here of the left side of the
receiver and it's not bad at all the
markings aren't quite in the form that
they are on the real thing but it does
say us model model 1928 rather model of
1928 which is what it should say a
really odd looking picatinny adapter on
the upper receiver i kind of hope that's
not real but i'm sure someone in the
comments will inform me that it is in
fact real and there are people out there
butchering their wonderful thompson with
picatinny adapters and it's got a
suppressor on it and there's a red dot
sight on that picatinny adapter um i
don't see on the face of it that's the
only reason why you couldn't use that
picatinny adapter i think that would
work as long as it's not interfering
with the cocking handle now on the
cocking handle the reload on this does
not seem right basically magazine comes
straight off magazine goes on gets
slapped into place that's not
recommended on a thompson and more
importantly you cannot fit the magazine
with the bolt forward
i have to say that the general depiction
of the tommy gun here thinking back to
the many others that we've seen in other
games is pretty good rate of fire seems
about right controllability
probably
okay i mean this thing does climb up and
right
if you're not used to handling it we
don't have the cuts compensator fitted
however somewhat reducing felt recoil
would be the suppressor now you're
probably wondering about that suppressor
is that something has ever been fitted
to a thompson well as it turns out yes
here it is
this was done by sport 4 special
operations executive in the uk and it's
not the same configuration as we see
here this one is actually
sleeved over the barrel and from memory
i believe it's integral as well i think
the reports in the barrel of this one
but suffice to say
yes you can suppress a thompson this was
never actually issued for service this
was um experimental only maybe there
were functioning issues with it
i haven't had a chance to look into the
research side of that one and this is of
course an m1 so it's a different model
that is depicted in pubg but as we often
find this is almost certainly
coincidence they're just trying to allow
you to to modify your weapons in the
game as all multiplayer shooters allow
you to do now they wouldn't have known
about this or and why should they care
frankly but there is a real one
deux i'm sure there's an even more
correct pronunciation out there it's
definitely not daewoo or daiwu and the
model in the game even says made in
korea we have a couple of k2s
in the collection ours does not say made
in career on it now the k2 is a very
interesting
firearm plenty of videos on youtube for
a deep dive on that it is essentially
a
distant cousin shall we say of the m16
it's very much ar-15
ergonomics
but with
distinctive changes made by south korea
and it is the standard service rifle to
this day
of the south korean armed forces now
this thing definitely doesn't have the
marking pubg military weapon industry on
the side of it i don't think i need to
explain that one thing they seem to drop
the ball here on
the muzzle device because i mean this
has a sort of elongated take on the
m16a2 type birdcage flash hider open at
the top or top left sorry top right
that's not present on the game gun that
just has a
barrel that just ends abruptly so i
don't know if this is customizable and
you change the muzzle device but the
stock gun really should come
with the stock flash hider
on the real k2 and it doesn't
the burial that the polish take on
modern take on the kalashnikov there are
a whole series of polish aks and this is
the later or the latest in military
service anyway now the version that's in
regular standard issue with the polish
army
is the 5.56
millimeter version translucent magazines
as you can see now the rifle in the game
has conventional ribbed steel russian
magazines the uh proper burial mags
should be translucent polymer so you can
see
how many rounds you have left it's um
not a bad representation of minor
details like a nitpick like the shape of
the rib on the top cover here i'm having
to notice the latch for the top cover is
a slightly different shape that kind of
thing but not nothing sort of
catastrophic i suppose the only the only
thing that looks a bit janky is the
selector which is actually an
interesting feature of
the barrel
it has the conventional ak safety
selector with a
platform for operating with your firing
finger
to make that easier on the right hand
side but it also has has some
ak variants do a left side
selector so this becomes now just your
safety not a not a safety selector as on
the original design and you'll let your
firing hand thumb
now operates this bioselector so they
have decoupled the two controls making
it a little bit more
ergonomic for quick operation
of
the selector
i think this is a perfectly serviceable
rendition of the winchester 1894 model
1894 or the winchester 94. now so there
isn't really much for me to say i don't
think there's nothing visibly wrong or
done particularly amazingly well with
this this rendition of the of a
winchester now the scope on this thing
i'm not sure what model of scope that is
offhand it looks period enough to be mid
20th century or first quarter of the
20th century maybe you absolutely can
and people did fit telescopic sights to
winchester rifles they might need a
modification to the ejector so that they
didn't jam themselves up by trying to
pump cartridge cases straight up in the
air as they traditionally did but i
think the way this one is depicted is
actually okay and we
for once we don't have picatinny rail
which is nice
next up is the digirev dp uh sometimes
called dp27 dp28 it's not the dpm though
tell that from the lack of a pistol grip
and the big
swollen butt that it has so it's what
you call the dp27 or dp28 um i just go
with dp because as far as i know there
was no year as part of the official
designation we're nerdy like that this
is weirdly short now i might be missing
something there might be some variant
out there that's shorter but this has a
very short barrel on it proportionately
short cooling jacket on the gun so
answers in the comments as to why this
is such a short version of the dp it's
got some rusty bits on it which i
suppose is appropriate for a legacy
firearm this is as the numbers would
imply from the 1920s 30s they are still
around still being used in conflict
zones what they don't have though is a
picatinny rail adapter in place of the
rear sight
at least i suppose all they've done is
replace the rear sight but it still
feels like sacrilege on the vintage
firearm like this to have picatinny
rails on it but i understand why they're
necessary it's got the classic record
player action
of the rotating pan magazine on top of
it that i'm sure most of you are
familiar with it's it's an okay
okay version of the gun i think
except for being
too short
[Applause]
right so in game this gun is called the
s 1897 is of course a winchester model
1897 in with heat shield and bayonet lug
so in first world war military trim you
like now despite that name on the gun on
the action bars which is a really weird
place to mark a gun it says m1897
and it also says shotgun i don't think i
can think of a single shotgun that has
the word shotgun written on it because
it's a shotgun main reason for
mentioning that is it's got the correct
model designation on the model of the
gun but in game it's s
don't know why doesn't seem to be as
effective as you might like but then
you know
shotguns against body armor are not
nowhere near as effective as
without put it that way hard armor
plates of almost any kind will stop what
would otherwise be a devastating blast
from a 12 gauge shotgun so maybe that's
what's going on here something they
haven't modelled that would have been
fun is the slam fire ability of the
1897. so most pump action shotguns uh
quite deliberately for safety reasons do
not allow you to hold down the trigger
and pump the grip so that it fires every
time the pump goes forward again which
the 1897 famously didn't have that
safety feature and so you could do that
and we have attempted that as part of
some filming for our first world war
project a few years ago takes some
practice but you can definitely unload
the thing pretty quickly you can imagine
it being very useful in the trenches
just as useful would have been that
bayonet now we have the lug on here to
fit that bayonet two mounting points for
the bayonet i assume there's no bayonet
mechanic i'm not seeing one in use and i
can't imagine pubg going the bayonet
route
mp5k the mp5 as those of you watch this
series regularly will know my probably
my favorite modern firearm so i'm going
to be quite exacting when it comes to
this one now this is meant to be the k
model here is a k model
don't be distracted by the by the gold
first impression
is
it's too short i don't know if you can
see
um or whether the clip will line up with
this let's do some editing magic i'm
sure it will so this whole front section
of the gun i don't think it's just the
angle i'm viewing the thing at it it's
too short there's not enough travel here
maybe maybe only slightly too short but
still now the sight's missing is not a
problem because this is uh the
concealable version of the mp5k that
just has a pistol style front blade
and then a notch on top of the receiver
as the rear sight so basically just
pistol sights most mp5ks have the
standard hk mp5
iron sights that you see on this gun so
that is not incorrect now it's obviously
missing the iconic
front grip as well that's not too
unusual but the critical missing bit
here is this finger stop here
because i have spoken to several people
who have used the mp5k shall we say
and shooting your fingertips off with
this gun is a thing and that's with the
finger stop on the gun overall not
bad um our example i've chosen simply
because it's gold because it fits the
whole video game uh
but not this one funny enough uh this
version is an old-fashioned trigger
mechanism housing grip frame with the
old molding so the one in the game is
not wrong it's just the later
version of it
[Applause]
well that was bizarre we got some
bullets sparking as as they hit
something which is a frying pan now i've
heard about the legendary pubg frying
pan would a cast iron skillet stop nine
millimeter paraben rounds please don't
go and check or at least not without
proper safety precautions i don't think
it would uh cast iron is pretty brittle
and nine mil is fairly pokey so i think
ball rounds would probably zip straight
through that thing unless it's a i don't
know an ar 500 frying pan which uh i'm
sure somebody is thinking of marketing
as we speak
there's something terribly wrong about a
bolt-action sniper or any sniper rifle
i've both but a bolt action especially
with no
sights on it now this thing looks like
it's got a front sight blade of sorts
that doesn't look right to me for the
m24 this is meant to be the
american military m24 sniper weapon
system and it's not there's nothing
egregiously wrong with it but i think
that they seem to have interpreted what
i believe is just a
base for an optional iron sight as a
very massive front sight blade that you
can't in any case see because it's not
taller than the action so when you have
no sight fitted to this you have no
einsteins almost almost turning it into
a musket with a little blocky front side
could you use it without any aiming
point well yeah because you have an
aiming point superimposed anyway
this has gone terribly wrong i'm afraid
so this is on the face of it this is an
m16a4
so the m16a4 is the m16a2 that we all
know
with the flat top upper receiver which
is fine that's that's on here what i've
immediately had a red flag go up for is
the barrel profile so the m16a2 and a4
have the same heavy profile barrel
however what they've done here seemingly
is take the barrel from an m4 and
stretch it out so we've got an elongated
sort of wasted profile in front of the
front sight block it's only there on the
m4 so that the m203 grenade launcher
could be mounted directly to the barrel
so that it would have a portion of
barrel the same diameter as the a1 rifle
that the m203 was designed to fit so it
was a clutch
on the m4 and that's why that
distinctive notch is there in the barrel
there is not such a notch on the m16a4
because under the handguards it has the
right diameter barrel to fit the 203 and
you replace the handguards with the
whole m203 grenade launcher unit so the
barrel forward of the gas block forward
of the front sight block should be a
constant diameter and it isn't
and it is uh yeah not right
all right we've got a
slightly horrifying version of the p90
somewhere under all that is
a p90 tactical the tactical model is the
one with this
big chunky blocky picatinny adapter
replacing the original ring sight this
iteration has some bizarre fore end on
it i'm sure that's based on a real thing
but nothing comes to mind the magazine
looks
overly thick and low detail compared to
the real mag so i mean this is this is
does not feel like the it's not steel
it's a polymer mag but it's sufficiently
robust for for use and it's thinner top
to bottom it just the mag doesn't look
right on the gun there
our p90 is the conventional upper
receiver with the tactical rail adapter
in it it has a little
front sight post the front there and
then
a little rear aperture at the back
really quite a clever way to have a
backup iron sight for an optical rail
the setup in pubg is not that i'm going
to speculate that that is a ps90 variant
we don't have with an
integral picatinny upper receiver so
different design there so this it's not
or at least this iteration of the gun in
the game is not the p90 tactical i would
say it's a ps90 with a cut down barrel
converted to full auto if we were going
to sort of role play what this actually
is
[Applause]
it's probably worth
saying in terms of gameplay this for me
this represents the p90
quite well so it's relatively lower
damage which reflects the smaller
lighter bullets but it it's so it's
somewhat effective in the middle
distance is where i'm going with this
whereas a you know a machine pistol or
something would for a shotgun arguably
might fall off around the middle
distance this thing you can still get
enough shots on target which you can if
you tap off short bursts or even single
shots then it's still somewhat capable
in the 300 meters equivalent whatever
whatever that is that we're seeing there
super effective up close because of
course it would be very high rate of
fire very controllable reasonably
damaging projectiles so it in other
words nothing leaps out as as wrong in
terms of how it how effective it appears
to be in the game within the universe of
the game
i hope you enjoyed that one um as always
guys we have our
our own channel you can go over and
watch and thank you to all of all of you
who've come over to the royal armouries
youtube channel and check that out and
we have the various social media outlets
that you might expect you can also have
a look and if you are in the uk you can
come and visit one of our three museum
sites as well links in the description
as always if you'd like to donate to us
no pressure at all in any case i'll see
you again next time
[Music]
[Music]
you